un par de cosas la información que ya
tenemos hoy el día de hoy es que en un
principio están realmente teniendo una
política que discriminaba contra una
grupo específico ya han habido muchas
artículos científicos muchas
investigaciones donde prueban que
realmente todos los estereotipos que se
tenían de más cantidad de hiv de otras
cosas más pues que realmente no podían
comportarse con todas las personas de la
misma manera que hay grupos que se
pueden Designar que tienen más HB y
otras enfermedades sexualmente
transmisibles hay grupos también
heterosexuales que también tienen los
mismos riesgos y no se le aplican las
mismas leyes bueno Cuáles son las
pruebas de rigor que se realizan previo
a una donación de sangre para comprobar
que la persona está sana
de entradas se Checa para h&b todas las
enfermedades importantes que se pueden
transmitir por medio de la sangre esta
idea era en un principio crear y
disminuir los riesgos que una persona
que al momento de de darles Esa esa
unidad de sangre va a poder estar sanos
en este momento sabemos que tenemos una
disminución de donantes tenemos muchas
cosas que están pasando en el mundo y
sobre todo con Coby 19 muchos de los
bancos de sangre están teniendo
problemas para poder atender eso y por
eso teniendo la evidencia científica y
además la importancia de tener ese banco
de sangre listo para cualquier momento
que cualquier área de nosotros
necesitemos necesitamos ampliar y seguir
ahora sí no no los estereotipos sino lo
que realmente dice la ciencia podríamos
considerar esta de alguna forma una
iniciativa que busca luchar contra la
estigmatización
que en forma personal definitivamente
porque una persona que lleva una pareja
sin importancia es hombre hombre mujer
hombre mujer o cualquier definición que
tengamos Pues realmente tiene los mismos
riesgos que cualquier otra persona más
lógicamente Si una persona heterosexual
tiene múltiples parejas también
incrementa su riesgo entonces de esta
manera estamos poniendo algo de de
equidad algo de de Justicia para que
podamos tener todos la misma oportunidad
de donar sangre